hello everybody my name is markiplier
and it's time for another successful
procedure okay there was an update to
surgeon simulator which includes the
medic and heavy oh god no
I've forgotten how to play I've totally
forgotten how to play but I'm gonna get
this you can't stop me this time game
I remember your secret oh yes
don't bug me right now I have a very
important mission to accomplish so
excited yeah hello heavy how we doing
today
oh you don't look so good no what seems
to be the matter
Samantha do you need the medic gun oh I
can't use that oh man oh this is so cool
maybe you need a little booze to ease
the pain of this procedure glug glug
glug glug glug glug you just keep that
in there and then I will return later
where's Archimedes Archimedes No get
outta here Archimedes
oh yes oh my god the solemn vow ah
oh my god hold on oh no oh no no oh yeah
I need to calm down I'm just a little
bit too excited here okay how do I open
this
oh please tell me the spies head is in
here oh my god oh my god Oh freaking out
I'm digging out man come on come on give
me get a carrot obey there we go there
you get open
oh the mega baboon heart does heavy want
to sandvich ah come on
oh come on I want this sandwich No
okay fine then your sandwich for you
until you're done you don't look so good
are you in pain little man okay stop
being such a baby
oh I cannot it's so cool it's what does
this do
and what is this just whoa Oh reroute
okay just need to get it a little over
to the left back a bit right Oh where's
it going whoa whoa almost at it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa there we go
good enough it should help
yeah it ain't so bad dear okay so I need
to take this here wrench and I need to
smash up ever so delicately lift the
wrench and then just smash this [ __ ] out
of all of your ribs
excuse me heavy man oh man your ribs are
tough god I got something in my eye
again why I did it I can't stop I won't
be stopped
mr. heavy you think you could stop me
just because they're not my medical
license just think that you can stop me
okay
enough going crazy huh let stop me my
eye I can't stop must continue procedure
blind they didn't give me any sort of
saw which is what I normally use to
break open the ribs but I suppose this
hammer will do just fine come on you son
of a [ __ ] break ragnar oh right
why aren't you breaking maybe because
I'm holding this or no or no you did it
what mother Fajar God up okay all right
you know what this is not working I'm
going to drop this turn it and then pick
it back up again this is now arcing or
now working on price eriously have
something in my I'm like permit Abel
you're all oh no
okay the axe is gonna have to do come
here you son of a [ __ ] you gave me no
other goddamn choice here so I have to
you
appropriate force son of a [ __ ] mother
humper snagglepuss frag tides okay it's
my okay now okay I have a game regain my
sight and I am now what get out of there
Connor son of a [ __ ] you know what I
think you deserve this heavy after all
the shiz how you gave me earlier I think
I owe you you owe me a few things don't
you think don't you think burn buddy
friend oh it's that you want some
healing juice well let's just see what
we can I don't know how to raise this up
and okay raise it up by going back a bit
no whoa whoa okay can't go down any more
this raises it up no whoa whoa whoa
raise it up shoot him full of healing
juices that's getting it that's this
these devices don't obey me
everything should obey me cuz I'm the
doctor
and guess what everybody I know what is
best
okay enough freaking out come on just
son of a [ __ ] mother humping go bad
head don't cough which means stupid head
in German speak come on it's okay it's
okay we got this all under control
everything is gonna be fine
what have I got a holdup I thought I had
the lung maybe I had some that war Oh
Gavin okay come on son of a [ __ ] what
is going on in there I don't even know a
screw it screw it I guess this spies
knife is now my scalpel I just need to
start cutting things willy-nilly through
that sir or madam you gonna
you son of a [ __ ] oh you mother humping
everything is so tight in there
and I did not mean that in any sort of
sheshu there we go okay got it out
losing blood quickly I have no idea how
to stop the bleeding but I need to get
that heart out of here
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
I'm gonna make it hang out just get out
of there long long if you know it's good
no time I don't care man now is oh it's
tough I had some in my a Chipotle
napkins thank you very much
dammit dammit alright
true enough
I don't ever saw oh wait yes I do wait
whoa what is this what is all this then
what's all this then I'm just having too
much fun with this I need it oh you son
of a [ __ ] oh really
really is that what I want you to do oh
oh is it son of it you're just making a
mockery of me you don't know what it's
like you don't know what it's like to be
an amazing doctor and no one recognizes
you for your amazing talents you see
what I have to deal with every day
don't you thought you heavy you bastard
you did this today or I'm doing this to
you hang on sign of a patch mother
Humbert gut oh this saw your ribs are
like seriously your ribs are steel buddy
your ribs are like harder than any other
ribs in this entire game this is
unbelievable
I was already inside of you and then you
just decided to clam up god damn it you
son of a [ __ ] you're making me do these
things I don't want to do them
you're making me doing just Blanc you're
right in the head
if I could ever control these
appropriately long walk does that hurt
huh
what oh you want more archimedes
like all the [ __ ] back Archimedes
wait no Archimedes
how you doing over there you're doing
good you're doing good buddy doing good
coming I just want a polka eyes out of
my range and I just lost my back son of
a [ __ ] this is hard it's like harder
than any of the other ones that I've
ever tried cuz I don't happen if friggin
tools are not appropriate for medic
going and I can't grab this fire axe why
not why not God dad son of a [ __ ]
solemn vow get out of here
son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna kill someone ah I'm sign of a
war really really that's what I want to
do just run it gently just kind of slap
them around a little bit with the blunt
end of the axe ah yeah there we go there
we go that's what I wanted yeah yeah God
dig it all out from the inside out
telogen penis the nipples the areola you
don't have a vagina but I don't know
baby you do who knows I don't know these
things
god damn it damn it yeah you kidding me
what is this [ __ ] what is this you see
this what is this oh I'm going to Jack
slap you so hard when I get this out of
your stomach
I'm just bearing it deeper you know what
might as well keep going at this point
come on get in there yeah I'm not a
doctor from Nicaragua now I'm a doctor
from sha sha my mom my mom texted me
ya know she was a nurse at one point
the medic doesn't need any finally got
it out of there now I'm just gonna keep
hammering away random orifices right up
here face donk
did that hurt in your eyeball what what
you want to say something to me I'll
tell you acts oh oh sorry that's shut
you up there didn't it god damn it I
can't do anything cuz it all sucked so
bad yeah screw it screw it I'm taking up
the solemn vow to must do no harm my ass
just shove it in there just get it in
there whatever all you can this guy's
name Apollo Apollo Creed I think that
was this guy's name
no Hippocrates Hippocrates hip rock
it's the Hippocratic oath god damn it
must do no harm which I probably forgot
know at this point in this venture I've
almost got the ribs excised and he's
only got a thousand liters applied a
[ __ ] let's smack the [ __ ] out of you
stupid heavy you think you can deal with
me just think you you deal with the
pressure I don't think you're supposed
to winning this one I don't think this
one's intentionally meant to be harder
so I can't get it cuz I'm terrible at
this game I think we've already
established it I'm bad at this game and
me as a medic I'm not any better okay
anyway so try it for yourself the update
is totally free see if you can beat it I
certainly can't let me know if you want
me to try it again I don't want to but
you guys do whatever you wanna do so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
sorry about that Bob you feeling better
now
feeling better Bob ruining my reputation
you know that
and this stupid clock I'm so glad that
they approved in the catechol my arm
ruined me last time you ruined me in
Nicaragua you all ruined me now now
let's try the sauce strategy again grab
the saw firmly there we go now as I am a
professional you need to exercise the
thoracic cavity one rib at a time